hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from round nine of
the Gibraltar trade wise chess festival
here we have a Russian Grand Master
Valentina Goo Nina against Nigel short
the legend and you've already seen one
game from the Jupiter chess festival by
going Tina guna a debt game she played
against Hikaru Nakamura I also made a
video about it it took Nakamura a
hundred and thirty five moves to win
that game he gave up his Queen for two
rooks
and it wasn't a winning position but in
the end he managed to win so definitely
struggled with her and okay the title of
this video might be it might seem a bit
harsh but it's something Nigel short
said and it's something that's gonna be
following Nigel for the rest of his life
and when you say something like that you
you don't want to go around you know
playing tournaments and losing against
women that's definitely something you
don't want to do I don't want to forget
here is something I found in the
database database here is a Nigel shorts
lifetime record against unit polgár so
in classical games you did polgár beat
Nigel short six to three with five draws
somewhere I saw it was eight to three
but this is the classical I mean this is
the just database the original ones so I
think six to three is the correct one
with five draws and if you're looking at
rapid and exhibition games unit beat
Nigel six to zero so that's quite quite
a result and I really don't see how
Nigel could have said something like
that but let's get back to this game in
the description below you will see a
link following to the article that will
tell you something more about this whole
idea and I shall had about women not
being able to play chess do check it out
I was gonna do a video about this game
as soon as I saw it but it was a Gordon
radish actually who sent me this article
so thank you for that so all of you can
enjoy it and also there will be a link
in the description below where you can
check out an interview with Valentina
goo nina after this game do check it out
as
you know she's happy out of this world
so let's see this game we have a four by
GU Nina and Knight to f6 short goes for
the Allium defense and GU Nina said in
an interview that she was preparing for
the French but short had the black
pieces and he obviously wanted to win so
he tried to surprise her would that
would delay him we have E 5 Knight to d5
d 4 d 6 and now not going for c4 but
actually going for Knight to f3 this is
also my favorite variation to play with
the white against the alien and as we're
already in this variation I would just
like to show one neat little trick you
can use in your bullet games for example
if black continues with Knight to c6 you
can use Bishop to c4 and after the
bishop is attacked you can play Bishop
captures on f7 King captures Knight to
g5 this is with check King goes to g8
and now you play Queen to f3 you
threaten checkmate and f7 here black
will stop this and now you push east 6
and in this position I whatever playing
bullet or maybe even blitz a lot of
players will push h6 and if this happens
you can achieve a very easy victory with
Queen to f7 black has no choice the
knight is covering age 7 he has to
capture and now pawn captures on f7 and
this is checkmate so this is a one of my
one of my favorite tricks to use in the
Asian if it's not a serious game of
course you don't play this if it's a
serious game in the game and nigel
didn't go for Knights he says he played
the g6 we have Bishop to e2 Bishop to g7
C for now kicking the knight Knight b6
and E capture some v6c capture some d6
and we have castles by both sides and
Bishop to g5 not allowing black to play
any six or maybe five ideas we have
Knight to c6 now h3 we have Bishop to a5
Knight to c3 and now h6 Bishop to e3
we have d5 now c5 comes kicking the
knight Knight see for attacking the
bishop on e3 and also the pawn on b2 so
Bishop to c1
be six and here we have b3 attacking
that night and here Nigel played a very
interesting move B captures on c5 he
decided to sacrifice the knight on c4 we
have B captures on c4 and now we have C
captures on d4 now nigel is attacking
the knight on c3 and here you do have a
couple of options let's say let's try
Knight b5 if you play Knight b5 this
doesn't really work because of d3 this
kind of locks your bishop in also it
allows this bishop to capture the rook
on a1 and after we play Bishop captures
and Bishop captures now both of your
looks are attacked from the bishops so
after Queen captures the light square
Bishop Bishop captures rook and now
Bishop captures on h6 attacking the rook
and opening up a discovered attack from
the roof to the bishop and here you you
want to play Bishop to g7 but this isn't
actually the best move Bishop to g7 then
Bishop capture screen captures and we
and after C captures on d5 Knight has to
move somewhere and then you have then
you have all sorts of Quintus III ideas
followed by h4 h5 95 is coming so this
would be this would be okay but it's
hard to say if white can really do
something here so better after Bishop
captures on h6 would be Bishop to f6
actually and now after you capture the
rook and King captures Queen captures
Queen captures and pawn captures you
have this night the b4 move and Nigel
would be winning back one pawn the
material would be equal but nigel would
have a bishop a bishop for a night and
after white probably gets rid of this
pawn Nigel will have the passed a pond
so it will be a better position for
black in the end
so after this C captures on d4 move
Knight captures on d5 was played and
here you have ecigs this is the best
move after Knight captures on d5 now d3
isn't the best idea because now the same
variation bishop characters
capture screen captures Bishop captures
and Bishop captures on h6 now you have
Bishop to g7 and after Bishop captures
and King captures you have Queen to c3
check and now you'd have to ruin your
pawn structure probably by going f6 and
the white will be better here if you go
something like King h7 King h8 then
again h4 h5 95 are all ideas working in
White's favor
so after this Knight to d5 move east six
was played and what do you do here
that's a question I mean your knight is
attacked here let's say you want to
defend it you can't really bring it to
be for the knight is guarding that
square c3 is covered by the pawn III is
also covered by the point so let's say
in Knight to f4 here now you get d3 and
now after Bishop captures and Bishop
captures Knight captures Bishop captures
rook and after Bishop captures on h6
Bishop goes back to g7 now Bishop
capture skin captures and after Queen to
a1 check let's say Queen to f6 blocking
the check and Nigel keeps keeps the
exchange so much better position for
black probably winning so a lot of
things to consider here and always you
have to calculate this exact same
variation after every move so after each
six you Nina goes for Bishop to a3 now
attacking Nigel's rook and f8 so here
definitely a critical moment in the game
what nigel should have gone for is rook
to e8 simply getting the rock out of the
way the knight and d5 is still attacked
but after Knight to f4 now we don't push
d3 immediately but you have this e 5
move and after you kick away the knife
let's say 95 not now pull d3 and after
Bishop captures now comes F or attacking
the bishop and night and after Bishop
moves you simply capture it Bishop
captures protect the knight and c6
getting the rock out of a8 and a much
better a much better position for black
so after this Bishop to a3 move nigel
didn't go for rook to e8 he decided to
play a captures on d5
captures on a fait King captures on f8
and now C captures on d5 attacking
Nigel's knight on c6 Queen captures on
d5 and here we have Bishop to d3 night
before with a double attack on the
bishop on d3 Bishop captures Queen
captures and rope to be one we have
Knight to d3 rook to be seven King goes
to g8 and we have Queen to be one with
ideas of rook to b8 at some point Queen
to d5
we have rope to b5 attacking the Queen
Queen c4 and rook to d1 now with a
double attack on the night here and here
your only move probably is to play
something like a six but even this
doesn't work for black after rook checks
rock captures Queen captures and King h7
simply queen back to b3
again with a double attack on the night
you have to trade Queens here and after
Queen captures and pawn captures you
have to move the night and now night
probably captures on D for protecting
the B trip on you
Europe the exchange and you're winning
this game so Nigel saw this and he
decided that rock a6 is just a losing
move but it will take some more time and
he'd play Knight to f4 he got his Knight
out of the way but he missed an even
greater threat here goon in a played
rook to b8 check and in this position
Nigel short resigned the game
why didn't I shall resign the game well
if you haven't seen the game feel free
to pause the video and find why Nigel
resigned it's not difficult but you know
yeah in positions like this you want to
find it for ourselves so those of you
who found it congratulations and those
of you who maybe haven't if you move the
King to h7 you simply lose the rook on a
a so that's pretty terrible and if you
capture it then comes Queen character
Sam b8 this is with check and after you
move the King notice that the queen is
now attacking the undefended night on f4
so King moves and Queen captures on f4
now go Nina would be up a whole rook and
this is quite reasonable there's no
point in continuing a game like this so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said after rook to b8
short resign the game and you Nina won
this great victory against Nigel short
also it took her almost she got got a
drug in saqqara Nakamura so quite a
tournament for her and quite a success
congratulations to Valentina
and you know you don't want to say
things like women can't play chess and
then go around playing moves like this
and you know it's just terrible for
Nigel so yeah like I said do check out
the interview with one Tina goo Nina you
know it's a very rare that you will see
such a happy person it doesn't matter
who you beat but you know it's just
refreshing to see such a happy person so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with a game that will decide
the winner of the trade white Gibraltar
chess festival but also I think there
will be a tie so there will probably be
tiebreaks so yeah thank you and I'll see
you soon